philosophy for our times is brought to
you in partnership with the new college
of the humanities a university level
college offering undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees in the heart of
London NCH pride themselves on offering
unprecedented access to a world-class
academic faculty philosophy students at
the college are taught by some of the
foremost scholars in the field and
one-to-one tutorials create a
personalized teaching experience choose
your major and minor for a unique
combined honours degree and study the
NCH diploma to widen your appreciation
of the world in ways you never thought
of before go to NC h london dot a c dot
uk'
for more information think better think
NC h hello and welcome to philosophy for
our times the podcast which brings you
the world's leading thinkers to debate
today's biggest ideas our topic today is
to consider whether recent advances in
neuroscience can really deliver on the
idea of telling us how better to
understand all the aspects of the human
mind human cognition emotions all sorts
of features of our consciousness and
experience can that be simply explained
as a as as a result of understanding the
matter and the mechanisms of the brain
this week our speakers explore the
latest developments in neuroscience to
find out if it can provide the answers
to who we are are we our brains and no
more than matter and mechanism or just
neuroscience still need to account the
experience of life and all the meaning
and purposes
taking this on we have neuroscientist
poets and author of AP mankind
Raymond Tallis German philosopher and
author of I am Not Afraid
Marcus Gabriel a neuroscientist a
science writer susana Martinez one day
please make sure you subscribe to
philosophy for our times to never miss
an episode
head over to iTunes and give us rating
and a review if this helps other people
find our podcast and of course check out
all the episodes we have an offer back
now varices me you host this week's
episode meaning purpose the feeling of
who we are is going to be something that
we can hope to capture in
neuro-scientific terms and I'm going to
ask ray to start off please Barry thank
you very much indeed my brief answer is
no but you're entitled to a little bit
more than that because I'm going to
argue that our minds are not just what
goes on our brains and my starting
position is that while our brains are a
necessary condition for our having minds
and indeed being conscious subjects they
are not sufficient in themselves so
there are therefore serious limitations
to what neuroscience can tell us about
ourselves full disclosure I was a
researcher in clinical neuroscience
investigating stroke and epilepsy for
several decades and of course this has
reminded me as if any reminder when
necessary that the brain is indeed a
necessary starting point for our mental
abilities bash me on the head I lose
consciousness chop my head off and my IQ
falls a little strokes and seizures
interfere with functions ranging from
the most basic tingle of sensations to
the constructed most constructed sense
of self but that's the beginning not the
end of the story of what we human beings
are so the question you want to ask is
what is the origin of the gap between
the necessary and sufficient conditions
our human consciousness
well it's called intentionality
intentionality is the aboutness that
characterizes mental phenomena
perceptions are of objects perceived as
being out there emotions thoughts and
memories also have this aboutness now
there are two important points to make
about intentionality
relevant to the question of whether
neuroscience will eventually explain our
minds the first point is that
intentionality is entirely different for
an anything observed in the macroscopic
material world where the interaction
between objects is typically causal such
causal relationships are seen throughout
the brain and are investigated by
neurosciences the light that lands on my
retina causes nerve impulses in my
occipital cortex the impact of a
stimulus causes a bit of brain to light
up but causal causality explains how the
light gets into the brain but not how
the gaze looks out and sees illuminated
objects so intentionality puts paid to
the famous claim expressed by Daniel
Dennett that we can in principle account
for every mental phenomenon using the
same physical principles laws and raw
materials that suffice to explain
radioactivity
continental drift etc cetera those
physical principles laws and raw
materials are the very stuff of
neuroscience but they make a poor job
indeed no job of explaining a Baroness
nor do they explain some of the most
basic features of human consciousness
and here's a couple at any given moment
I'm aware of a multitude of things my
voice droning on your presence the
pressure of my feet on the floor a few
memories and so on and they belong to a
unified field of consciousness and there
is no neuroscience model of how they're
all brought together and we can discuss
that and here's another at any given
moment I'm explicitly aware of the past
and I'm pregnant with the future towards
which I'm traveling this kind of
temporal depth is not seen in material
objects including the brain the brain at
time t1 is the brain at time t1 period
that's my first point the second is that
intentionality is the seed that opens up
the space between the material brain and
the human world this is most evident in
vision vision where we register a gap a
distance between what is happening in
our bodies and the visual world that
surrounds us but this is just a start a
small difference grows into a big
difference intention ality or aboutness
is developed to an extraordinary
indeed unique degree in human beings we
might discuss the reasons for this but
it is primary due to the extent to which
we share or join together our intention
ality
out of trillions of cognitive handshakes
we create a human world that interacts
iteratively with our individual minds
the scale of the individual
distinctively human world is a measure
of how far the human mind the self the
person is from the brain even though the
brain of course remains a necessary
entrance ticket for our participating in
this world let me end with a metaphor to
peer into the darkness inside the skull
in an endeavor to understand love agency
history or culture is like placing a
stethoscope on an individual acorn in
the hope of hearing the whispering of
the leaves in the wood one final point
that we collectively transcend our
individual brains courtesy of
intentionality is evident from the fact
that we have the word brain and we even
meet to discuss whether or not
neuroscience could tell us what we need
to know about the mind thank you ray
thank you raised mind or brain was
keeping track of that too the second
very impressive thank you so Susanna now
we're going to ask you the same question
do you think that issues of higher
cognitive functioning states of meaning
and purpose will eventually be explained
in terms of mechanism and matter so a
lot of the research that we do in my
laboratory has to do with the neural
basis or perception with a focus on
illusory perception and due to this
about ten years ago I became very
interested in the neuroscience of magic
tricks that is how magic works in the
brain and along the way I decided that I
should study magic myself not just as a
neuroscientist looking in but I thought
I should gain the inside perspective of
the magician to really
what is entailed with putting together a
magic routine and I ended up auditioning
and gaining membership as a magician
member of the famous Magic Castle in
Hollywood which was a lot of fun and in
also a great research investment but
then people started asking me nothing
you know so much about magic do you
still enjoy it or - no magic feel a lot
more mundane and magical and my answer
has always been that uh
on the contrary I do enjoy magic a lot
more now that I know more about it than
before I started studying it in fact I
didn't pretty much care for magic shows
before I learned about magic myself and
I find them really fascinating now the
reason that I'm telling you this story
is that when I was invited to
participate in this debate and I read
about some of the questions that we
would be addressing today this
particular question struck me are we
just our brains and it reminded me of
how so many people think but if they
really understand magic the whole
experience is going to be ruined for
them so my position in this debate is
going to be there are yes or feelings or
thoughts or emotions or experiences are
the products of our brain but that
doesn't make them any less so I mean I
am curious why this word just I think
are we just our brains
why does it feel that we are somehow
diminished if we are the product of our
brain mechanisms our art our science our
humanity even our philosophy are the
products of our brain and they're
intrinsically fascinating
after all we are a small piece of the
universe trying to make sense of itself
and that is huge already even if there
is nothing else than that we have that
as for the question of meaning how can
life be meaningful if we are our brains
my answer to that is how could it be our
brains our meaning seeking machines we
are wired to find the link cause and
effect to find purpose meaning to make
sense of things whether or not the
reality around us is fundamentally
chaotic and disorganized so we can trust
our brains to find meaning our brains
will not fail us in fact the hallmark of
a healthy brain is that it finds meaning
we wouldn't be here today if we and our
ancestors for ian's did not feel somehow
that life is meaningful and worth living
in fact one of the ways in which our
brains find meaning is by convincing
themselves that they are somehow more
than brains Susana thank you perfect
equally impressive timing so we're
setting a good standard now for Marcus
again the same question all of these
facets of our thinking and reasoning and
feeling will they resist capture in
neuro-scientific terms is there
something that will always elude
scientific explanation here yeah given
that the question was slightly different
than the one post array I can say yes
but I will mean by yes what Ray meant by
no however so let's look at why so race
had a lot of things too which I
subscribe so I think what he has said
about intentionality you know with a few
modifications or something I subscribe
to I also agree with them even though
this is very contentious philosophically
and scientifically that the brain is a
necessary but not sufficient condition
for what I will now call human
mindedness so let me just tell you what
I think the question is about right
there's this very complicated question
are we you know a pack of neurons etc
but if we even begin to try to answer
this question with you know a look on to
what's happening in neuroscience and in
the history of philosophy including
contemporary philosophies so if we even
begin to answer the question we
typically have already settled the
meaning of AI in MI my brain now what am
I after all is a good question before we
start answering the question whether
whatever I am is identical to my brain
right well I think I have a justified
opinion about Who I am I think I am the
animal that you currently see right so
there's this animal and it has a past
and a future and now if I am this animal
then trivially I am NOT identical to my
brain or any pack of neurons because I
also have fingernails and hands and so
forth in the past etc so on this level
it's kind of trivial that I'm not my
brain right so we have we need reasons
to think that we are and typically
reasons to think that we might be our
brains despite the obvious fact that we
are not they go something like this
well look your capacity to identify
yourself as the animal that you are
consciously and with the help of you
know meaning driven linguistic
articulation as the one that I'm
currently making use of that capacity is
nothing over and above the activity of a
certain part of your brain be it the
central nervous system or a part of the
brain etc we know it's not the brain as
a whole because you can cut out certain
things from the brain and that is still
there
no one knows currently which parts of
the brain are the neural correlate of
what we call consciousness anyhow so
it's not the case that we can ask
current neuroscience in this respect
however it is true as Ray said that if
you take off my brain then my
consciousness is gone right and probably
the whole animal that will depend on the
survival conditions of the animal that I
am whether I am still there
but not as to speak off this utterance
so let me tell you a little bit more
about what I think I am okay so I said I
am this animal but they're slightly more
than that okay so I'm also not willing
to accept that I'm identical to the
animal that you see ok I'm clearly not
my brain but I also don't think that I'm
identical to the organism that you see
I'm a very specific kind of animal and
so are you namely a human animal so what
makes us human animals and now I'm a
German philosopher so I have vocabulary
that you don't have let me tell you what
it is but I'll translate this in a
second ok into something that you can
understand so the word is Geist ok
but let me tell you what it means ok
otherwise it's just a big word ok so
guys this the capacity to lead a life in
light of a conception of what kind of
animal you are this corresponds to the
definition of sapiens and Homo sapiens
given to us by Carl Linnaeus who did
define the human animal by an improv he
said know thyself Northcote ipsum if you
look into his book system under - ok
this is the definition of the human
being so human beings lead their lives
in light of a conception of what it is
to be human
ok so if you think you have an immortal
soul I don't think I have one ok but if
you think you have an immortal soul
you'll do certain things in a certain
way right you might think that you are
currently tested by God whatever
you know you'll have problems
masturbating because God is there and so
forth right however if you think that
you're a complicated intelligent killer
ape okay which has evolved in a certain
way and your consciousness is it's a
good mechanism to spread your genes
you'll behave in a different way so this
capacity to lead a life in light of a
conception of what you are is what we
call Geist and Germany and I think this
has absolutely nothing to do with
anything specifically material about my
body thank you so thank you for that
German philosophy made accessible we had
we had spirit animal masturbation it's
all in there so what I want to do now
that we've had the position set out by
our speakers I want to break it down and
pursue some of the topics and I I want
to come back to Marcus and the issue
about his claim I'm not my brain so he
set out very nicely the idea that that
can't be true because you might be
tempted by a kind of animalism view that
you're a certain animal certain kind of
animal one that has a capacity to be
self-aware to think about conceive their
ends their values and so on so I suppose
the question that we want to press you
on now is whether instead of thinking of
the whole animal the self that you
identify with whether mental capacity
some of mental functioning is that going
to be fully characterized or not fully
characterized by looking at let's give
you the whole nervous system not just
the brain yes let's press on that for a
while oh yeah there in this respect
absolutely so I think for absolutely
water yes Tory absolutely it is
absolutely the case that some of the
terms we use in order to characterize
our mental lives our human mindedness
such as sensation perception depression
anxiety and so forth right the taste of
wine so some of the vocabulary we use in
human life is going to be such that the
best understanding of the meaning of
that vocabulary
we'll have to invoke our best neuro
scientific knowledge
so I've no doubts about that precisely
among other things because the self is
an animal so some animalistic store is
going to be true and animals have
evolved in some branches in a very
complicated evolutionary genealogy of
human beings so of course we'll know
something about for instance our
experience of color right I mean why do
we experience certain elements of the
Lightwave as color and other others as
heat for instance we don't see alt
revile it but we feel it as heat so we
can explain this and many other things
with the help of neuroscience and
medicine and so forth so quite a bit of
the vocabulary that we deploy and think
of as specifically mentalistic really
refers to processes in the human
organism but not all of it but more than
we thought and neuroscience pushes this
border the more it knows further into
the human mind but if I'm right it will
never get the whole thing into view just
more and more so could you remind us why
I won't get the whole thing I mean
you're seeing that it's the border or
boundary is changing but you want an
in-principle reason why yes so I there
agree not quite for the same reasons
with raised reference to intentionality
so for instance I am currently aware of
being in London right so now you can
explain what this conscious awareness
takes on the side of my brain there's
going to be a certain hormone regulation
my brain has to be in certain states etc
there has to be a certain dynamism that
you can look at etc otherwise I couldn't
be aware of being in London but given
that being aware of London essentially
invokes London right and London is no
state of my organism it is false to
think that you can account for my
awareness of being in London by known
everything about my organism so if an
alien comes to Planet Earth and would
know everything about the animal that I
am it would not dare I know that I'm
aware of being in London so I'm going to
bring in Susanna I want to just press
you on one part of that and Ray will no
doubt have things to say
- certainly people can lose their sense
of being aware of London we can see
things that will mean that that's no
longer available to them yes with
neurodegenerative disease does that give
you any more sense that it's very
dependent on the particular organization
of the brain well I think this will
always tell us more about the necessary
conditions of a certain mental state
that someone can be in and that just
means that if you take away the
necessary condition you take away the
state right so yeah but you can also
destroy London and then I cannot be
aware of being in London so I might then
be under the illusion of being in London
but London might just have been
destroyed right I mean whatever happens
Germans don't do that anymore and no no
I know I know you do that yourself now
we do that ourselves
yeah these days but but Susanna could
could could you come back on this I mean
they're here we've got a sense that of
other things that neuroscience is able
to to get at there are I think states of
a byte Ness about large and complex
objects where somehow we need a
Constitution relation that involves not
just what's going on in us but perhaps
the relation to something outside that
won't be captured in purely neuro
scientific terms I think London is
fundamentally accidental to the argument
and I think it's actually quite
irrelevant because I may be dreaming
about London and I would sustain that
that's a conscious awareness about
London even if it's incorrect and maybe
in Germany or what have you but I'm
still aware of London we thought London
being there ultimately it comes down to
the brain processes that are happening
and if the structure of my brain and the
neural activity in my brain are
indicating that we are in London then
for all I know I could be a
brain-in-a-vat right now receiving
appropriate electrical stimulation in
fact the activity in my brain right now
that is telling me that I'm here at how
the light gets seen participating in
this panel would
not be any different to what I would
have as a brain-in-a-vat
if I was having the same type of
activity going on in my brain I assume
in my brain was maintained in a healthy
state and so forth that brain in that
that would believe that it is me
speaking in this panel being in London
and we thought London actually being
there so the reality that is external to
our brains the conversations that we
have with people the air we breathe and
so on that only matters in that it
affects our brain States so I know that
Ray doesn't agree with that and I
suspect Marcus either but you want to
pick that up as to whether it's exactly
the same state with the same content
whether you're just a brain in a vat and
there is no London or even dreaming and
whether you're actually in touch with or
seeing or thinking about London I'd like
to figure out up in the context of
something excuse me that Marcus said it
seems to me that there's something
absolutely central that the life we lead
is actually determined to some extent by
the kind of creatures we think that we
are that's what it is to lead a life
rather than merely act out a biological
prescription I think that's something
absolute central and where do we get
that sense of who or what we are from we
get it from the community of minds so we
have to recognize there is something
absolutely central about the community
of minds which is not implant in a
particular brain that actually shapes
the kind of persons that we are and
that's why the brain in the VAT
experiment one of the many reasons
thought experiment doesn't work the
first is you have to assume that
somebody has put the brain in the VAT
that there is an outside world of people
creating this kind of situation so where
is it presupposes the very things the
outside world that the brain in VAT
experiment plays with suspending but the
other thing is that yes you could indeed
get experiences from stimulating the
brain and let me give you some very
striking example from the canadian
neurosurgeon Wilder Penfield he was
operating on patients who had epilepsy
in order to make sure that he wasn't
damaging important parts of the brain
he would stimulate the brain while the
patients are awake and they could report
their sensations and some patients when
he stimulated them actually had quite
complex memories and you may think that
rather goes against the case that Marcus
and I have made against the Bray against
the notion that the brain is a
sufficient condition of experience no it
doesn't these were waking patients so
already wakefulness was present and
they'd had those memories in the normal
way first of all so let me just end by
reminding you about the difference
between a necessary and sufficient
condition we're talking about London in
order to be knocked down by a bus in
London I have to be in London I'm very
pleased to say that that's not a
sufficient condition of my being knocked
down by a bus in London
otherwise I wouldn't be talking to you
today that's fine but I want to surely
that's true exactly but I want to press
you a little bit on this idea of not
being a single brain because even even
if we're not wedded to the idea of
brains and bats there's a lot of social
neuroscience going on now where people
are interested in the effect of one
brain on another they are you going to
feel pain differently if you're aware of
another person present what about a
group of people can that influence the
physiological and mental states of
people in a way that's to do with their
nervous system so I mean I can see one
might be against a certain kind of
individualism but but have you got the
wrong target and thinking the only
target here would be a brain-in-a-vat
but something more distributed more
social that might sustain some of the
things you're talking about much more
distributed we want the irritating
things you find is the toothache settles
down when you go to the dentist and
that's a very good example of the kind
of thing you're talking about suddenly
the toothache matters less but hang on
why does it matter less there's a whole
institution of the reassurance that we
get from people who've been qualified as
dentists at cetera cetera and you can
already realize that the authority of
the dentist and your reassurance comes
from an extraordinarily complex society
the society that I've described as being
put together out of a trillion cognitive
handshakes we still need our brains of
course it's a final common pathway
but what our brains are tapping into is
something that has been built up over
hundreds thousands of years and that's
the culture that you can't find by
looking at the brain I repeat the
metaphor I gave it towards the end of my
talk trying to look at the brain and
finding things like love and wisdom and
so on
and it's bit like listening to the Acorn
through a stethoscope and hoping to hear
the Whispering Woods the community of
minds is absolutely central to what it
is to be human being and that is not to
be found inside an individual brain ok
so there's an anti individualism but I
want to press again the idea of what's
missing and what's left out because
because suppose that susana is actually
happy to concede to second person and
and and social neuroscience and and
connectors our brains have evolved as
part of us being social animals so we
don't live in isolation but society our
links with family friends and so on that
those are going to affect our neural
activity they're going to affect the
neuronal connections if I make a new
friend my brain is not the same as
before I made this friend so ultimately
it comes down to what's happening in
your brain structurally and functionally
and as for not being able to find love
under the microscope in in the brain if
you you can also they sick the heart and
you won't find your pulse there but
nobody would deny that your pulse is the
direct product of your heart functioning
and the culture is still looking for
love as far as I know but but let's go
back Marcus it you introduced this
tantalizing idea of Geist which we may
or may not wrongly identify a spirit and
it's very easy to hear that as a kind of
dualism that there's something floating
through you now ray wants to nail it
down in handshakes and other people but
but I suspect you don't quite want to do
that so is it a kind of dualism is there
something emergent is there something
irreducible there another kind of stuff
yeah that you're reaching for well
dualism is a thorny issue because you
know like I'm clearly not saying for
complicated reasons that are two kinds
of things and the
material things and mental things so I'm
not saying that at all however I do
believe that there are objects that are
immaterial such as the number seven or
the fact that I am in London right I can
think both about London and the fact
that I am in London and I will have
different relation relations to these
things so I think there are a material
objects and Geist partakes and them
however given that I do believe that
human mindedness is a state or a series
of states that animals can be in you
couldn't have a human mind without
having a brain so this is not dualism at
least of no traditional stripe however I
do believe that for instance take
language right the meaning the meaning
of our words such as skies or soul or
the mind or the brain and so forth the
meaning of these words is not identical
either to a state that one brain is in
or repetition of States or to a number
of states that all brains that have ever
you know thought that the word brain
have been in or a relation to things
that we interact with exactly well if it
were a relation let's say let's say the
meaning of the term brain is a relation
right say between brains and brains
so between brains and brains thinking in
terms of brain right between brains and
brains so that that could be fine
however the relation is not itself a
brain right so now you have brain and
brains but between brain and brain the
disk whoa tation is not a third brain
this will be the third brain argument
let's not go there
we've got enough trouble as it is right
but I'm still I'm still trying to
understand what you you said something
they are about I can't be a dualist
because I accept that do you have to
have a brain but but dualists Descartes
in particularly accepted we have to have
a brain and the dualism was precisely
because yeah there was something going
on or interacting with that brain yeah
that alone doesn't cut it no if dualism
of course but if do if dual dualism
typically means right there are two
kinds of things in the universe yes
right mental stuff yeah and non mental
stuff but I happen to think that there
trends finitely many kinds of things in
the universe
numbers cities earthquakes bosons
fermions and so forth right so this is
not dualism because I think that the
other things that are neither minds nor
brains are not reducible to either so
technically it's not dualism that that's
philosophically important because we
should get it isn't a table really but
remember numbers if they're abstract
objects that means they don't exist in
space and time so they don't do any
pushing pool so if you want to Putin
yeah Geist with that we still have to
understand I think Susannah how yeah
that would make our bodies move and our
appetites flare and so it comes down
toward brain being able to accept input
information and and process it
if there is no interface with the brain
whatever else is out there is irrelevant
so yes having a pulse having a heart
rate it's not the same as having a heart
but I find that to be kind of trivial in
there having a mind it's not the same as
having a brain but the mind is the
product of the brain just like the heart
rate is a product of the heart and if
you don't have the interface you're not
affecting your brain structure you're
not affecting the brain activity and
then emerges will not be there just like
infrared light and ultraviolet light
there are there they don't affect us
because we don't have the neural
machinery to process that information
yeah so today I want to move on to the
next theme that we're dealing with and
that's whether or not neuroscience has
done some per sisyphic ation of some of
the topics that we're interested in so
if you take topics like perception taste
even you're dealing with things to do
with our emotional states we actually
perhaps have seen some way in which we
press off' eyed and got a better grip on
some of these issues so so do you think
that neuroscience might help us get away
from folk concepts that are too loose or
don't apply or is there always a danger
of changing the subject and trying to
explain things that we can get hold of
not merely changing the subject we're
losing the subject and it seems to me
that yes I suppose there are simple
correlations between brain activity and
sensations for example there are less
simple car
relations between brain activity and my
perception of an object that is
important to me and then you get less
and less correlations but the question
is where do we go from here where would
neuroscience advance from here to
understanding the kind of things that I
think personally are unique to human
beings so let's have a thought
experiment suppose in a hundred years
time we have a complete readout of the
total neural activity of someone who's
been in love for three months and we
also have a complete description of the
connectome a projects going on in the EU
at the moment two billion quid you know
how the brain is wired up etc cetera
what would be the result of that well
one result would be billions and
billions of noughts and zeros indicating
a neurons off or in neurons on do you
think you would understand anything more
about what it's like to be in love what
it's like very wise or foolish and so on
and the answer is no so clearly it's not
as if we're going to make much progress
- assuming these slightly higher order
things from perception onwards by brain
science one final point in relation to
perception the great Hubel and Wiesel
who were the great neurophysiologists of
perception won the Nobel Prize they
ended their lives I forgot which one at
what was saying essentially we don't
understand how edge perception and color
and the sense of distance and so on all
come together in the same spot for me to
be able to see that is my cup over there
so we don't even understand of
understanding how we unify your activity
or putative neural activity into a
perception of an object out there and
that's because there is no way that
neuroscience can handle intentionality
which is absolute fundamental to mind
above the level of pure sensation so
Ray's touched on the binding problem I
think they're putting it all together
but I wonder whether Susanna you can
think of examples too to offer array
where we talk about why there would be
some surprises things that we have in a
common sense we thought about vision or
thought about our senses actually get
revised when we find out how things are
actually working I wanted to address
four stuff that a human we
so did not end their lives because
Thurston we shall he still alive they
thought yes I I did I did trying with
David Hubel and to the rest of my
knowledge he never said you know I give
up
who knows what's happening we can get a
handle on it on the contrary he and
Torsten Wiesel develop functional
architecture and they brought structure
and function together and sure they were
a word that they had not solved the
visual system but they solve quite a bit
of the early stages and I think they
made a major contribution and
neuroscience is not finished but I think
that and it may be that we don't have
the methods it may be that we need to
reconsider a lot of the foundational
basis but but there's been a large
amount of very significant progress that
has been made and I would I would also
want to address the issue of love and
understanding what's happening in the
brain when somebody's in love to be sure
we're not there but that doesn't mean
that is not achievable and if we didn't
understand exactly what it means from a
neural basis to be in love I think that
it would be much easier to come up with
very practical applications like maybe
see people want to fall in love or they
want to fall out of love and if we
understand how the brain is doing that
they may be a lot of people that will be
interested in gaining some access to the
neural processes and in have very real
applications there'll be a lot of
pharmaceutical companies interested in
that I think well it no I want to I want
to move on to our final topic and to ask
you
Susanna so do we need new concepts when
we're dealing with some of the questions
that have always interested us so
philosophers will talk about perception
and they'll talk about you know often
using vision as the only model so
they'll say you know I see an apple in
front of me or I'm I see a tree or a
human face and so on but as a visual
neuroscientist might we have to change
our categories for what vision is I mean
I don't know where you stand on it but
if you think of two visual pathways one
for recognizing types of objects and one
for acting
might we have to fractionate some of
this talk might we have to have new
concepts of what a visual experience is
well you have gotten at the binding
problem I didn't I didn't address the
issue that all of these sensory streams
and even within a the visual system we
have a form and motion and color and so
forth that they somehow get put together
and we don't have an answer for how that
comes about that doesn't mean that there
is no answer were just not there yet in
terms of vision itself I would say that
first off there's a lot more crosstalk
between are these two different streams
that was originally believed even though
they're still relatively segregated at
least in there absolutely
streams are oh we're talking about the
emotion stream and the and the color
pathway and and so on but uh somehow
initially along the visual pathway there
kept I'm simplifying a bit but they're
kept in separate channels and then of
course we don't see we see a moving dog
a moving brown dog we don't see motion
here and then separate from it the
concept of or the perception of brown as
the dog scholar it all becomes
integrated that's the binding problem
how do all of these different elements
come together and that's that's a big
one to resolve which which we don't have
yet but but I wanna go back to vision
and and just say that in my own research
we were talking about it in the in the
green room that we see even that we may
think of something that is its own a
compartment visual perception it's a
there's a great interlink with our with
our eye movement so vision itself is a
very active process we don't just open
our eyes and see the world but we
actively sample visual information
through through our gaze and through our
emotion so we need to think about all of
these of visual and temporal aspects
coming together and perhaps we wouldn't
have the same visual scene if our sense
a balance of a stimulus system wasn't
working
we wouldn't be anchored even though we
were getting visual information it
wouldn't it wouldn't feel or look the
same so so there's a lot more to do but
I want to ask Marcus about this idea he
brought up the idea of who I am and self
but I'm wondering whether we also need
some new concepts there because we might
have concepts of self very big in
philosophy but we might distinguish that
from a sense of self and perhaps you
could have the latter without there
being anything referred to by the former
and then even with sense of self
philosophers working with
neuroscientists like Sean Gallagher have
distinguished a sense of agency when
your limbs are moving from a sense of
ownership is that my limb and we see
with various pathologies people who've
got one without the other so so do we
need neuroscience to provide us with new
concepts even to get the phenomenology
and the philosophy focused in the right
way and what we're interested in well I
think this has a much less philosophical
impact than many philosophers believe so
I think of course we should take into
account what we know about humans right
for medical reasons and because we are
curious and interested in facts and so
forth right and this can lead us to
introducing a philosophical term such as
a sense of self and say something like
you know like if a dream I have a sense
of self right it's possible we don't
know whether this is actually
empirically possible that a
brain-in-a-vat would have a sense of
self we don't know these things by the
way and what you have just said about
human vision is it tells me that it's
empirically even false so if we need
movement I movement and so forth to have
vision then brains an event couldn't
have a vision as a matter of empirical
fact so these are interesting facts
about humans and we should take them
into account and sometimes this can have
consequences for our philosophical
conceptions but I think fundamentally
the answer is indeed no all right what
about Ludwig Wittgenstein saying a man
could not be in pain and wonder whose
pain it is and yet we have patients who
have alien hand syndrome they think this
isn't their own hand if you prick them
there's
and you say is there pain yes whose pain
is it I don't know maybe it's yours
yeah so was pickin Stein wrong to say
that
oh yeah that's a pain as a wonderful
issue of course because it's one of the
best known cases both in natural science
and philosophy to come to terms but our
you know philosophical concept use there
so I do disagree with Vidkun Stein's way
of putting it so I think he's making
philosophical mistakes right and they
can be corrected with reference to some
of the things we now know this has big
consequences indeed because we
understand much better which was known
in philosophy ever since people starting
started thinking about the non conscious
contribution to human thought right I
mean you get this from Plato onwards the
realization that there are two kinds of
things the one thing is the state that
you in and the overall perceptual or
mental state that you in and then
there's an additional state that you get
activated into when you become aware of
that state and neuroscience helps us to
understand that this is the right
philosophical model right there debates
and philosophy about whether this is the
right model for self-consciousness are
there two kinds of states that you're in
when you become aware of your awareness
oysters just one state I think
neuroscience helps us to push the
evidence in the direction of what
philosophers call anti luminosity that
just basically means that the state that
you're in and your knowledge of that
state are two states that's why I
generally hold among other things
inspired by conversations with my
colleagues in neurobiology that there's
no state that you can actually be in
such that you cannot be wrong about that
state and Vidkun Stein and Descartes and
many other people thought that the mind
is precisely the kind of entity that has
some privileged States whatever they are
pain right and I think there aren't any
such privileged states my arguments for
that do not rely on neuroscience i if I
gave you my arguments they wouldn't
refer to neuroscience but I think
neuroscience nicely confirms okay so I
think we've got we've got at least clear
where the speakers are so so maybe we
could say that Marcus thinks that
neuroscience might be useful for getting
the evidence or the
phenomenon right to start philosophic
philosophizing in the right way we're if
we've got the right thing in view and
neuroscience might help us that will do
susana thinks even our philosophizing
and the things that we're doing that's
that's going to be a product of the
brain and that with a bit of like an
optimism we might get to understand how
we can do that
andrey thinks that somewhere other our
culture more widely is going to be part
of the distribution of mindedness
impinging on individuals and that
nothing entirely about the brain is
going to satisfy so no will you join me
in thanking our speakers raiment Alice
Susan Martinez condi and Marcus Gabriel
this episode
philosophy for our times the podcast was
brought to you by the Institute arts and
ideas it was hosted by me and I carry
and I guess this week for Raymond talus
Marcus Gabriel and susana Martinez Conde
as ever please do let us know what you
thought of this episode make sure you
subscribe to 45 times and of course tell
anyone you know that might be interested
tune in next week for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the institute of arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you